je crois que c'est une organisation qui
a commencé tout d'abord avant tire les
fondations avant de mettre la couverture
c'est en 1970 aux côtés de rené
lecavalier que gilles tremblay fait ses
débuts à la télévision comme analyste
des matchs des canadiens à la soirée du
hockey deuxième période pour trambly
c'est le début d'une deuxième carrière
après celle trop courte de joueurs des
canadiens de montréal 1960 à 1969
régulièrement à la gauche de jean
béliveau le rapide patineur originaire
de montmorency connaît cinq saisons de
plus de 20 bus et s qui sont non deux
fois sur la coupe stanley mais des
problèmes d'asthme de pouce à 30 ans
vers une retraite prématurée de la glace
à la passerelle gilles tremblay devient
alors le premier athlète analyste à la
télévision canadienne
je compte la première fois que joueurs
portent l'uniforme du canadien il hérite
d'une motivation légendaire ses
connaissances du hockey et son amour du
sport il les partage avec le public
durant 28 ans 28 ans c'est quand même
beaucoup pour un analyste
ça prend beaucoup de patience pour les
téléspectateurs de couvrir la durée bada
réduite
témoin privilégié des performances et
des exploits des canadiens durant près
de trois décennies
gilles tremblay véritables ambassadeurs
du hockey prend sa retraite en 1999
on va retirer officiellement son veston
de la soirée du hockey
trois ans plus tard l'association des
commentateurs de la ligue nationale lui
ouvre les portes du temple de la
renommée du hockey en lui décernant le
trophée face chez hewitt mais c'était
quand même une cale exceptionnel pour
moi seulement que de voir demeurer dans
la même sphère a été pour moi un gardien
un grand bien aussi pour les amateurs
qui s'ennuient déjà de cette
personnalité sincère et attachant
françois faucher radio canada montréal